hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
simultaneous exhibition now morphe held
against eight opponents
uh simultaneously uh in birmingham and
it's uh well it's going great so far
only one loss for morphe but that was uh
that was a beautiful one
if you haven't seen it do check it out
uh the link to the entire morphe saga is
always in the description below so even
if you're just starting out you are more
than welcome to join
so here uh morphe's opponent is uh
william right out wills and he is uh as
it says uh the secretary of the
birmingham chess association and also
one of the organizers of the birmingham
chess congress
now there's uh some there was some
dispute whether this is
his opponent or a gentleman with a very
similar name
uh but i think the the general consensus
is that
this was in fact morphe's opponent so
without further ado let's check it out
it's quite a nice game so let's see what
happened here morphe with the white
pieces opens
as he usually does with e4 uh we have c5
by will uh we have knight to f3 knight
to c6 and
now d4 striking in the center we have
captures captures and
now e6 going for the taimano variation
of the sicilian
even though of course it was not called
that uh in 1858
uh and here bishop to e3 now levanthal
was giving some of his suggestions
during the game and he was
saying something like knights to b5 is
the go to move here you should kind of
play this
and while in those days uh great games
were one with knight to be five to date
that is not uh
that is not the case so morphy goes
bishop to e3
morphy really enjoyed the developing his
bishops to e3 and the d3
uh we have knight to f6 and now bishop
to d3
uh we have e5 and this is a this is a
weird move to play as it kind of wastes
black a tempo
uh but he really wants to get rid of
this knight so here
e5 uh the problem is while you do get
rid of it this knight
this point this pawn will remain a
backward spawn forever
and there will not be all that much you
can do about that so here
knight captures b captures black is of
course hoping to get the d5 in at some
point but morphy just
castles and now d5 although it seems
possible because the d5 square is
defended twice
uh would run into complications for
example if d5
captures captures and now c for going
after that center as the black king is
still in the center of the board
we have d4 challenging the bishop and
let's say bishop to g3
and now yes you can develop your pieces
in castle that's not a problem but after
let's say bishop e 792 and castles you
get queen to c2 and now
you have some issues here the thread of
course is captures and then captures an
h7
and there doesn't seem to be a
a good way for black to deal with this
you you have to create some weaknesses
here and whatever you do
you're going to run into trouble for
example if h6 then just captures
captures
and after b4 you can see the position on
the queen side
uh it's just uh awesome for white white
already has a beautiful pass pawn here
and uh it's just a very easy position to
play
so i'm not sure if wilson knew all this
but he still decided to go with the
conservative d6
and okay morphe strikes in the center
with f4 this is a bit
risky by morphe but we have to remember
he is playing blindfold against eight
opponents
uh but here if someone did this to you
nowadays you go
knight ju for right away you wanna go
after that dark square bishop if you can
eliminate
uh white's bishop pair then uh knight to
g4
must be played and there's no way for
black to save the bishop if you move the
bishop then just queen b6 check
and the black wins king h1 i have to
check it's game over
so instead after f4 we have e captures
on f4
uh wills doesn't go for the for the
knight to g for move and now
just bishop captures on f4 bishop to e7
and now knight to c3 morphe continues
development we have rook to b8
going after the b2 pawn and now e5
uh morphy says your king has been in the
center of the board for
far too long we have to open up some
lines so here we have d
captures bishop captures also comes with
an attack on the rook so rook to b4
and now queen to f3 going after that
c6 pawn so here we have queen to b6
delivering check and
now king to h1 by morphe and only now
bishop to g4
and here we have a very very interesting
uh position that requires a lot of
calculation
so uh feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
morphe here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations as
this is not an easy move to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's queen to g3 morphy actually played
queen to f2 because he wanted to
uh have all the pressure along the file
but queen to g3
uh is very very complicated uh for black
to play because
the thread is uh well of course you can
see that if you eliminate the knight the
knight is no longer defending the bishop
the problem is
the rook is defending the bishop but
once you take all of this into
consideration
for example after this blackened castle
if black dares
but after castles the problem is a3 and
now you say
the rook cannot remain here and defend
the bishop and to make matters worse
if you go rook captures on b2 just
knight a4 attacks the rook and the queen
and if you try something else if after
moving the rook
uh there are no squares you could try
rook d4 to try and give up uh
the the rook for this very strong dark
square bishop
but white will even ignore you and go
bishop captures on f6
bishop captures and now knight to e4 and
now black is just lost the bishop is now
hanging
as the rook no longer defends it this is
being threatened you cannot move the
light square bishop because the king
occupies the same file as the queen
so this is just uh resigns uh for black
uh that doesn't really matter what you
do you'd have to give up the rook here
but it's
pretty pointless even playing this so
instead after bishop to g4 morphy had
this very sneaky
queen to g3 but he played queen to f2
instead and
offered a queen trade so yeah he was a
very confident in his skills
to play this with queen captures rook
captures and now
bishop to c5 challenging morphy's rook
maybe
even checking if morphe uh was uh you
know able to
conceive the entire board as he was
blindfold but morphy just moves the rook
rook after f1
and now bishop back to e7 and now comes
a3 finally going after that rook
saying that if you capture now it's
still not good because if rook captures
then
morphy will just play h3 and once the
bishop moves and knights to d5 and now
the rook is under attack here
doesn't really matter where you move it
let's say rook b8 uh rugby seven you
cannot go to b8
now bishop to a6 again challenging the
rook and now once the rook moves now
you're gonna go for knight to c7 check
and the black is not castling it's gonna
be a very very uh
tricky position to play uh for example
if king d8
going after the knight just to rook
eight to b1 and this is just a crazy
position uh if rook captures on c7 you
first deliver rook
f to d1 with check and now not much to
be done here knight to d5
c4 is coming so first just rogue b8
check
bishop to c8 and now c4 and black's
entire position is
tied up uh there there's uh
nothing nothing to be done here there's
no move black can make
it's just all gonna fall apart very soon
so instead of this uh greedy pawn grab
wills just goes back
rook to b7 and now knight to e4
we have bishop back to d7 guarding that
pawn uh
if you capture captures then the c6 pawn
might come under attack
so wills defends it and now uh he asks
morphy uh do you dare uh go for it and
morphy says even though i'm blindfold i
most definitely dare go for it
and he shows what he calculated here
morphy plays
knight captures on f6 and this is just
the start of a
crazy crazy line that you will not
believe that
that happened g captures an f6 with
bishop captures on f6
bishop captures rook captures on f6 rook
captures on b2 and
now rook to e1 with check bishop to e6
and
now comes bishop to f5 with a triple
attack on the bishop here
so king the e7 defending and now rook to
h6
going after the h7 pawn so wheels goes
rook h to b8 and off prepares this
tricky rook to be one move
but morphy just says i've calculated all
of this uh
at that moment when i decided to capture
on f6 and here
morphe just plays bishop captures on e6
and it looks crazy because
rook to b1 what happens then but uh
rook to b1 was indeed played and now
morphy needs to figure out a way
how to avoid being checkmated and how to
avoid severe material loss
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the only move
good for morphe while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able uh
to do it congratulations on not getting
checkmated or
suffering severe material loss and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's rook the g1 this is the only move
that gives the morphe a better position
uh problem is if you don't do that if
you play anything else if you capture
here
uh sorry that rook just moved to d1 for
some reason
uh if you capture on b1 is just made in
one captures captures this is checkmate
uh if you don't capture if you try
something like giving the king some
breeding room then just
captures it with check and after the
king moves real captures the black is
upper rook
so rook the g1 the only winning idea
and the morphe had to see all of this
when he decided to capture on f6
otherwise you just
don't don't go for that so here we have
f captures on e6 and now rook captures
on h7 with
check king to d6 and now rook captures
on a7 morphe now up two pawns
uh but okay it's not a problem the c
pawn will will fall so can morphe win
this being up only one pawn
so rook g1 check king captures on g1 and
now rook to b1 with check uh
checking the king with king to f2 and
now rook to b2
and now this pawn will fall but as you
all know uh
when you have a a position like this or
rather an end game like this where
uh you have an outside pass pawn that
you can push always remember
past pawns must be pushed so here morphy
starts pushing it and plays
h4 uh we have rook captures on c2 with
check
king g3 and now king to e5 trying to
trying to catch up to that pawn but it
really doesn't help but it would it
wouldn't help black even if you just
started pushing the pawn because
uh that that pawn will not be going
anywhere the king can just intercept it
very easily
so here he tried king e5 but just h5
king to f5 but just
h6 and now if king g6 h7 the h7 pawn is
defended there's no way for the rook to
catch up to it and h8 queen is coming so
after h6 we have rook to d2
uh preparing to block the pass pawn but
morphy just plays h7
and it was in this position that uh
william ryder will uh resign to the game
as
there is nothing more to be done here
problem is uh if you go for
rook to d8 regarding this pawn uh white
doesn't only have the outside passport
on the
h file but also on the a file and this
is just not possible to defend
uh for example i've rooked the g7
threatening rook g8
to cut off the rook's defense of the
square just to rook
h8 and now you start pushing the other
pawn and that's it there is nothing good
for black to play king f6 you're gonna
play rook c7
and then black might try something like
c5 to get you to trade pawns but you
just ignore him a5
c4 you're gonna play eighth a6 c3
and now after a7 uh c2 is no longer an
option because the rook just captures it
and if you
now capture this pawn then this pawn
queens so that obviously doesn't work
so after a7 you would have to play
something like king to g6 but then just
kink to f4
and black is without a move here there's
simply no move you can make here
and uh that's that's just it uh so
after h7 uh wills resigns the game and
yet another great victory
for paul charles murphy in this uh eight
men uh blindfold simultaneous exhibition
uh we uh we only have one more game
remaining that we are going to show from
this time
so uh you know brace yourselves uh and
then we are continuing uh
to to who knows what uh in the morphe
saga will the match with stanton happen
will it not happen
why will it or will not happen so it's
going to be it's going to be pretty wild
uh so and that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
paula [ __ ] matthew farrell
uh jonathan fish milan kuzmanovic and
alivatani for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
tour it's not in the chester the chester
is about to start but whatever else
happens in the chess world
is what i wanted to say uh so thank
y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day